with Nova nation behind him here in
Hartford Edwards gets his first parson
Edwards Edwards eyes off he's going to
take it
drilling back-to-back triples floor
number three in the eastern attacking in
top physical another second chance for
Purdue
[Applause]
Villanova so broad as the three-point
shooting around the revamped e block in
the lane opens up Edwards tries to the
gap drills it Villanova finds itself in
a nine-point hole early because of
Edwards 12 of the last 15 for Purdue's
Gillespie misses from three there's
enric back into the hands of Edwards
parson Edwards step back on City pay how
tough is that one Oh Jim Cornell
out of our very talented crew of women
and men here in a Hartford Connecticut
Edwards have to board off the patents
bit the biggest issue for Villanova both
ends to build all the defenders there
with Edmonds he gets back to Milton
throws it in reverse
that's the first two and it's in
spectacular fashion
Robert riders need to sell ball foul
Edwards
[Applause]
you take a little deeper to the shop
[Applause]
we'll give him a chance at three more
it's now 27 in the game for Carson
Edwards with 30
he's got the intense look in his eyes
looking for a third straight sweet 16
and now Edwards
[Applause]
threes in the game and 33 on the board
for Carson Edwards we're do over and
Eric somehow gets past Gillespie
Purdue's roster 15 threes in the game to
do they average 10 best in the big 10 of
Matt Peterson
Samuels arms keeps it alive into the
hands of Carson every chapter to Carson
who's display
[Applause]